you've had all this success and and and
people love the Billy on the street
segments and then you start certain
celebrities people that you probably
admire have become mega fans if you're
as Nicki Minaj yeah has said not too
long ago that you were her hero yeah and
she posted a clip of you yeah Instagram
that she said was like her favorite
thing probably on the street yeah I'm
going in the street can we show the clip
that Nicki Minaj and cuz it was going
viral and Nicki Minaj yes she saw it and
she put it out there and she kept
tweeting about it and posting about it I
went up to a young woman in New York and
I asked her about the movie lala land
when that was coming out a few months
ago and this is what happened let's take
a look yes are you lying low until all
that lala land hype dies down well what
lala land oh honey I don't know what
you're talking about Emma Stone who Emma
Stone I'm sorry babe
Ryan Gosling okay I know who that is
okay it's a movie musical in LA
definitely not going to LA no you don't
have to go to LA and it's just a movie
about LA yeah I'm sorry I'm sweetie
don't babe me okay lala land a lot of
Oscar buzz could be Emma Stone's here
for kids I'm not watching TV but
sweetheart okay and has Oscar buzz and I
saw Emma Stone do a QA alright
[Laughter]
absolutely right she's absolutely
correct argue with that
now you must have been I would have been
frightened she's really mad I mean I you
know I thought it was really funny and
it's rare that someone can be that quick
yes and respond to be terrific yeah I
mean that's not scripted we didn't even
cut anything out no no it happened in
real time and Nicki Minaj saw this clip
and fell in love with it and and we
ended up having this sort of like
private message on Twitter me and Nicki
Nicki Minaj a new private email exchange
on Twitter what was that like it was
amazing and and but well I love Nicki
Minaj but she wrote mostly in emojis yes
it was all it was a long conversation
but it was a lot of emojis and I was it
was like trying to like you know figure
out hieroglyphics you know like it was a
little hard to fake was like Morse code
but it was very charming and exactly
what I wanted from Nicki Minaj yeah yeah
that's great
please save all of those and read them
here next time you're on the show I well
and then towards the end she got very
you know like very businesslike because
she's a great businesswoman too and I
was like oh you should come to Billy on
the street sometime she was like I'm
recording right now but we'll see okay
whenever people say that to me I know
I'm never going to hear from them again
there's no emoji for scheduling conflict
you